for the last year I've basically been
crippled by lower back issues I mean i'
I've had trouble there are days when
I've had trouble getting up and walking
I mean it's been that bad yeah I mean to
be honest Tim you first told me about
this like 8 years ago or something
remember when you got those injections
or something you like you were like I
think I have degenerative dis disease
yeah so I've had lower back issues for a
long time this is also a congenital
issue so I have what's called a uh trans
addal segment in other words the there's
a segment in my lumbar there vertebrae
in my lumbar area that really mimic a
sacral vertebral uh segment and that's
problematic for a host of reasons
creates an abnormal angle and if you can
imagine just bending the paper clip over
and over again in ways that it shouldn't
be bent that's sort of the feeling in
the low back and my brother has this
there are other people in my family who
have this issue so standing extended
slow walking like a museum walk cocktail
party type of experience can be very
painful like the low back locks up but
in the last year specifically had all
sorts of issues and all sorts of MRIs
and Specialists and PT and adjustments
and traction and this that and the other
thing and it was a disaster and it
caused it well let me give myself a
little more agency I created a lot of
anxiety around this because I was like
[__] is this the new normal right is is
this really The New Normal where well
cuz you you project forward like what
what is 5 years from now look like yeah
I'm like I'm not that old right you know
and I'm pretty active and your skincare
is amazing my skincare is amazing I saw
your Instagram video you know what's
funny you
sidebar is how much time you can spend
on like a blog post takes 6 months to
put together and it's like you get like
crickets and a fart in the wind and then
nobody ever reads it again and then
someone on your team is like you know
what people ask about your skin care
let's grab a couple clips and throw it
up and it goes bananas I'm on I'm on
Instagram and the first thing that pops
up to me is like hi I'm Tim Ferris
people ask me about my skin care regimen
let me tell you I use Bronner's natural
soap or whatever like I like what the
[__] is come into yeah so here we are F
here we are folks your skin looks
amazing though breathaking coming back
to the the main through line here
terrifying experience with the back and
I I had more or less given up I was I
was in the stage of grief where I was
trying to get past denial and accept
that this might be the new normal
because no one could figure it out and a
lot of the advice I received many of the
diagnoses were conflicting and then
decided in part because of this to do a
few things and part of that was going to
South America which I'm not recommending
there are a lot of risks down in South
America it's generally like safety fifth
it's not safety 1 so people get into a
lot of trouble but I went down and did
this did this training which involved
consuming a bunch of plants also
involved fasting for a week also
involved wait wait wait water fast water
fast Jesus seven days yeah also involved
during that
week really not sitting and standing
very little so he's either hammock or
cot basically and I'm mentioning these
things because they're confounders
Translating that into basic English that
means that I can't really point back to
one thing and say this is what caused
what I'm going to
describe but the during the first
experience which happened to be with
iasa which is a huge gun it's I think
treated very casually by people who do
not realize what they're signing up for
I do not recommend it to most people as
my ex who's going to become relevant in
a second would tell you I talk many many
many more people nine out of 10 which a
out of I'm not going to mention her name
but out my most recent X Out of using
iasa then I talk into using iasa like
nine times out of 10 I say you should
not proceed do not pass go for a lot of
reasons but in this particular case had
a very very very difficult experience uh
and I can kind of rank order my hardest
experiences over the last you know
decade plus and this would be the third
most difficult maybe the second for
different characteristics which just
saying a lot and there was a point at
which in that experience all I could
imagine was having my head in the lap of
my ax like that's all I wanted it was
the only thing I could even visualize
because I was in the Impact Zone I was
just getting hit by 100 foot waves from
every angle and there was no respite it
was 10 out of 10 there was no way of
meaning it didn't EB and flow it was
just 10 out of 10 volume from Peak until
end of the night effectively it was it
was unusual and Incredibly difficult
that was true for everyone in the
session your Shaman mixed the wrong this
guy's famous for having a brew that just
cripples cripples people and like like
yeah I mean there are a lot of other
full-time clinicians from indigenous
Traditions who will not drink his Brew
I'll put it that way oh Jesus and coming
back to the point of the story I'm
imagining you know the only thing I can
Envision is is this
woman holding my head and consoling me
that's the only thing I can imagine and
then I
realized that for a year because we
separated a bit over a year
ago and this was totally subconscious
right it wasn't a decision on my part
but I realized I had not allowed myself
to
feel the
complete
obliterating
heartbreak that was in fact
the core response to that separation
right like i' not allowed myself to or
from previous from that separation right
like in other words my psyche had
seemingly protected me because of my
history of depression right which i'
I've I've come to manage better than
ever before like each year I'm better
able to manage it and it's less and less
frequent it's less and less intense but
nonetheless let's face the facts in
college I almost killed myself right so
there's a
there was a fear at least
subconsciously that because of this
separation because of starting over it
at square one that I could spiral into a
deep depression and that could be
dangerous so my psyche protected me from
that by not letting me
feel the sadness the pain to the extent
that ended up being important which I
realized in this moment so I allowed
myself to soak in it in that moment I
trip reports are so [__] boring most
of the time and I apologize to people
who might be listening and thinking oh
here we go again because I get it trust
me but in this particular case I
experienced something I've never
experienced as soon as I soaked in that
and I really soaked in it and it was
awful it was so dark and so heavy and
then I felt my back release and
literally I've been 90 plus% painfree
since that [__] moment and it blows
my mind because at that point I couldn't
explain it with the fast because the
fast and ketones are highly
anti-inflammatory and I think that they
actually played a role hold on in the
durability of things but the fact that
there was an immediate release I was say
is interesting is is interesting I can't
explain that through fasting I can't
explain that through the just being
recumbent right laying down for 7 days
because cuz that was yet to come and I
would say that I made a a tactical error
in the last few weeks which is I was
like [__] man like I'm all good and so
I've neglected some of the basic
self-care and strengthening and PT which
I think is important because my low back
and ql and so on which are some of the
surrounding muscles have atrophied over
the last year of avoiding working with
the back there was that experience and
for people who may be interested in
delving into this a little bit more
there is a book I don't agree with
everything in the book but it is
interesting in the sense that it was
written by a western trained MD who
ended up then opening a healing clinic
in South America focused on Iowa and
diets which you will read about if you
get into the book called The Fellowship
of the river so I found that book quite
interesting on a number of levels but
the reason I bring this all up up number
one people had recommended this book I
think it's called healing low back pain
I may be getting the title slightly
wrong could be fixing low back pain but
it's by Dr Sarno John Sarno and this
book was recommended to me I've read it
before and the the general gist is it's
all in your head now I took great
offense at parts of this book and a lot
of it is scientifically indefensible so
he unfortunately I threw the baby with
the bathwater a bit because he sends a
he says a bunch of things that are
ridiculous and you know he he cites
these success statistics for his method
while Sim simultaneously saying if I
interview someone and they say they're
not open to a b or c i omit them from my
treatment and I'm like okay well wait a
[__] second your selection B is out
of control I wanted to bring this up
because that book has has helped a lot
of people despite its flaws and not
everyone will at at any point want to
consume iasa which I would advise
against for 90 plus% of the population
because it can be very destabilizing for
a lot of people and very risky I would
say there are a lot of things you should
do beforehand right like try the talk
therapy try holotropic breath work
consider after speaking with doctors
ketamine after that you can consider
other tools um but iasa should be like
let's do a fifth on your let's do random
show on iasa we could possible yeah
possibly yeah IAS would be like fifth or
sixth on the list of progressions it
would not be first uh but I would say
the Sarno books are interesting I know
they've helped people like Brian cman
who's been on the podcast amazing writer
who was the co-creator of billions among
others rounders
Etc and it's it's something that I've
always in theory agreed with yes we
store stress that that can have a
physiological effect there are
autoimmune disorders that I think are
intimately linked with different types
of psychological disturbances so you can
address the problem kind of from the
physiological side first of course the
brain isn't entirely separate there's no
kind of cartisian separation of mind and
body so yes the brain is physiological
but you can you can attack it through
content in a way or you can attack it
through Pharmaceuticals and Physiology
first I think you can go both ways but
the the Saro book I think is worth a lot
of people reading the second thing I'll
mention which is very very simple and
tactical if you have lower back pain I'm
shocked took me this long to figure it
out and say sitting on Hard chairs
bothers you or Lum lumbar support helps
you for a year I've been going to
restaurants and asking if they have a
cushion do you have a cushion or a
pillow or something I can use to fix
[__] up seating situations this is is
the solution right here this is it this
is a Pilates ball this is a prob body
Pilates it doesn't really matter but
honestly this thing folds up six in your
pocket and I've been traveling with it
I've had it behind my back the whole
time and like gra for First Dates gra
for First Dates ladies love Pilates
balls and I but I will say for instance
like the last time I did a podcast in
this seat I did not use this and my back
was [__] killing me afterwards but
the killing me afterwards is not just an
issue for today that's an issue that
causes inflammation that [__] up my
sleep for 3 or 4 days use this ball no
problem I can put it behind my back or I
can put it under my ass and it it folds
up and fits in your pocket so anyway
folks there you have it from the sublime
to the ridiculous Pilates
ball